on a un jeune homme voilà dans le public
aussi qui veut parler depuis tout à
l'heure un jeune homme de 20 ans peut il
peut se lever voilà c'est franck frank
franklin qui avait un temps bonsoir à
tous au moustoir france a perdu un oeil
sur les chante aussi
oui et je voulais dire un truc que j'ai
une vidéo qui tourne sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il ya une personne qui est
devant les forces de l'ordre avec son
gilet jaune qui tend les bras et qui se
fait tirer dessus par l bd qui qui alors
ils n'agressent pas les forces de
l'ordre et jette rien du tout il sait
tirer dessus sans raison
donc je trouve ça honteux juste les bras
tendus et s'est tiré dessus
c'est carrément immonde jeudi immonde il
faut interdire tout ça alors ces termes
là faut les interdire
on a avec nous depuis le début de
l'émission enfin depuis le début de ce
sujet antoine qui à 26 ans qui est
graphiste antoine toi tu t'es retrouvé
la parata moi j'étais ve république et
du coup le soir vers 20 heures quelque
chose comme ça et du coup il y avait des
crs à quelques gilet jaune y avait aussi
la marche pour le climat juste avant et
du coup moi j'ai voulu rentrer par chez
moi en fait et la rue était bloquée par
des crs
et justement c'est ça ma limite s'est
fait peur de passer par là du coup j'ai
dû faire un détour par une autre rue
donc j'étais déjà avancé à quelques
mètres de la place de la république
quand d'un coup comme ça de nulle part
j'ai reçu un truc en pleine tête et
vraiment violent quoi d'une puissance
que je pouvais même pas décrire je me
suis retrouvé au sol direct je me suis
relevé dans l'adrénaline pleins de sang
les mains comme comme j'ai déjà j'avais
jamais vu du sang comme ça sur moi quoi
donc
et autour de moi il y avait des gens qui
disaient ouais il a pris un flash ball
dans l'oeil il a pris il a pris dans la
tête je me suis relevé enfin les gens il
me regardait limite choqué quoi et
heureusement il y en a un qui qui m'a
aidé à regagner les camions de la
protection civile qui était à quelques
mètres heureusement et après voilà une
fois que j'étais là dans enfin je
comprenais pas trop je me disais
pourquoi alors que moi aucun moment je
me sentais en dise est en fait bien sûr
mais je suis là je fais rien j'ai même
pas de gilet jaune je suis même pas
manifestants et paf quoi j'ai reçu se
secoue la venue de nulle part quoi et
ben voilà du coup maintenant je sais pas
j'ai perdu un oeil alors que je suis
graphiste moi mon truc c'est le dessin
je vis de ça et et voilà maintenant je
sais pas encore comment je vais devoir
m'habituer à cette nouvelle vie quoi et
voilà c'est quand on entend des
témoignages c'est vrai que voilà linda
qui secoue dit quand vous vous dites que
vous entendez des témoignages comme
celui de de ludo iql moi j'ai juste
envie de rappeler qu'il ya de l'humanité
dans son discours il ya aussi de la
dignité comme l'ensemble des blessés qui
ont parlé au micro mais également
pendant les coupures avec lesquels on a
échangé et j'en suis désolé en fait je
suis pas responsable de ce tir mais j'en
suis désolé pourquoi parce que on est
dans un contexte tel qui fait que
forcément il ya des blessés et
malheureusement les blessés sont pas
forcément et personnes qui sont visés à
la base mais antoine sa vie alors
et mais bien sûr mais que je peut que le
comprendre mais pas en tant que policier
même déjà en tant qu'humain de sur moi
ça fait 15 ans que je manifeste suis
syndicaliste ça fait 15 ans que je crie
à l'injustice sociale
ça fait 15 ans que je dis que dans ce
pays rien ne va bien je savais quinze
ans que je dis qu'il a pris avec les
richesses avec avec plein de domaines
qui aujourd'hui sont pas dans le sujet
mais mais qui sont aussi la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui à des gilet jaune
et pour lesquels je partage du grand
nombre des revendications
et puis aussi en tant qu'humain et parce
que je suis aussi engagé associatif mais
même même sans ça je vais dire qu'
autour du plateau qui derrière sa télé
peut aujourd'hui dire non je reçois pas
d'abord je ressens pas d'empathie pour
lui c'est impossible
moi j'ai embrassé un métier par empathie
je vais embrasser un métier par
conviction j'ai embrassé un métier pour
aider les autres pas pour nuire pas pour
blesser des victimes
est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est un débat
idéologique on a des personnes qui
malheureusement les les -10 ne sont pas
forcément les plus blessé moi j'ai envie
de dire si jamais
mais quel que soit le domaine quand il
ya des erreurs elles doivent être
condamnés elles doivent être elles
doivent être condamnés nous sommes dans
un état de droit
le souci c'est que on est en train de
fustiger un corps une corporation
on parle de viol indiciaire attendait
des soins termine on parle de violences
policières comme si c'était systémique
comme s'il y avait une culture dans le
système comme si on avait voulu dire que
en fait les policiers en france sont
faits pour la bavure sont faits pour la
violence ça considérer un seul moment
que non les policiers sont là pour
défendre en fait son plan
sauf que c'est un discours que vous ne
voulez pas accepté et on en train de
dire qu'en gros qu'un système pied
humain avec tout ça parfait teinté
réflexion qui est celle de l'humain et
bah du coup on attend de lui qu'il soit
lui parfait soit en provoquant une
capacité de résilience jamais faire
d'erreurs et c'est ce qu'on nous rende à
chanter recto et si on est triste et si
on fait des erreurs mais pas dans ces
cas là on est les pires dans monstres
n'ont cure des montréalais lesage et des
années qu'on nous robotisée qu'on nous
désignait
juste un problème de jeu alors dans ces
cas là le problème que j'ai avec ce
débat c'est que des deux côtés je trouve
que vous avez de très très mauvais
avocat yann tout à l'heure qui s'est
égaré dans un discours évolution alors
faire plaisir à deux avocats et
heureusement bah oui il ya des bons
avocats nouveaux avocats rien de ses
clients et de l'arrêt de la cour
révolutionnaire du genre à venir jusqu'à
ce que vous tombiez tout ce qu'il a dit
à partir de là était d'aider légitimer
et vous madame je regrette vous faites
des grandes déclarations mais le font
d'autres affaires au lieu de dire ça ça
ne peut plus arriver ça ne doit plus
arriver des gens nous arriver sûr je
regrette
vous dites ah oui on est dans une
situation où malheureusement il ya des
pavés de certaines ce domaine et ce
matin en fait votre responsabilité saint
joseph et passionné sait comment il va
être responsabilité c'est de dire
aujourd'hui maintenant tout de suite
stop
quelles sont les mesures pour que des
drames comme ça ne ne survienne c'est
tout ce que je veux et pas un discours
voulant mais le taux zéro n'existe
jamais